[Music]
ever since the dawn of mankind we've
wondered what happens to us once we run
out of extra lives is it simply game
over or is there a bonus level or
spectator mode afterwards is there a
part of us that persists even in death
ghost stories have been around since
ancient times in some cases the stories
are meant to be comforting the idea that
our ancestors watch over us on the flip
side ghosts have become synonymous with
themes of horror an angry vengeful
spirit who can stalk and sometimes even
kill its victim if you're not careful
there's no shortage of ghost stories and
they exist in pretty much every culture
that has ever been whether it's folklore
songs books tv shows or movies ghosts
are here to stay and the same thing goes
for video games the zelda series is no
exception they've appeared as early as
the very first installment and have
continued to do so all the way up to its
most recent titles the idea of life
after death is quite prevalent in zelda
and similar to real life it ranges from
something positive like meeting the
apparition of a deceased ally who helps
you in some way to negative experiences
like evil spirits who serve as enemies
or obstacles the games make it clear
that the deceased can sometimes linger
in this world and one pass on to the
afterlife until they have achieved some
sort of goal find peace or are destroyed
indefinitely usually by force in some
cases it can even be that the dead are
unable to rest because of a curse
something that binds them to the world
of the living making them unable to move
on until said curse is lifted they come
in all shapes and sizes but the most
famous rendition of ghosts in the series
are of course their pose they are said
to be spirits of the dead that became
monsters because of an unresolved
attachment to the mortal world the most
common of which are the feelings of
regret rage and hatred it's hard to
pinpoint the exact rules surrounding
these spirits as they aren't universal
and can sometimes differ slightly
depending on the game they are featured
in for instance in a link to the past
and ocarina of time they can manifest at
any time even in broad daylight whereas
in the wind waker and twilight princess
they only appear at night or in dark
places the sun doesn't reach like caves
and dungeons the wind waker especially
explains that pose hates sunlight
because it makes them vulnerable to
physical attacks their abilities also
differ slightly from game to game in
ocarina of time they can turn invisible
for small periods of time during which
attacking them is impossible in the wind
waker they can temporarily possess a
living host rendering them confused and
disoriented for a while and in twilight
princess they are invisible at all times
and can only be seen an attack by
wolfling when using his special senses
we've seen many different designs over
the course of the series from hooded
raves with glowing eyes mask hoodlums to
imp-like puppets wielding a scythe all
with their own looks personalities and
abilities but there's one thing these
menaces from the afterlife have in
common and that is that in a lot of
cases they are seen carrying a lantern
sometimes a torch there are exceptions
here and there but the lantern is
definitely a design choice that has been
carried over all across the series even
when the design of the creature itself
is vastly different it is also apparent
that the lantern or torch is an actual
physical object for instance in ocarina
of time when a po becomes invisible the
lantern is the only thing that remains
visible and upon defeating them the
lantern will fall to the ground and
shatter freeing the soul of the po which
can even be collected this process also
reveals the true form a spectral flame
burning in various colours most commonly
blue orange green and purple although
every game does its own thing and sets
different goals and limits when it comes
to the lore behind ghosts there's
definitely an overarching theme to be
found that being one of lanterns or
flames whenever ghosts or spirits are
involved but why is that is it just a
random design choice or is it based on
something like religion stories or
folklore as nintendo is often known to
do for instance the famous ghost hand
seen in skyward sword is derived from a
japanese ghost story a story about a
spirit named hanako who may reach up
from a toilet to snatch up an
unsuspecting victim well as you've
probably guessed yes the flames and
lantern are probably derived from real
life stories as well the most likely
candidate being an old legend which has
been passed down for many centuries
the willow the wisp or will in the wisp
is an atmospheric ghost phenomena first
documented in the english language by
william falk in 1563. starting with the
latin ignis fatus meaning foolish fire
the term has seen many different
translations meanings and
interpretations the stories involve
mysterious ghostly lights often
witnessed during night time by
travellers the most common description
is that of a pale blue flame moving or
dancing around in the distance they were
mostly seen in and around swamps and
marshes though some eyewitness reports
also include forests and even graveyards
although willow the wisp is the most
well-known version nowadays at least in
western culture similar stories have
existed all over the world each with
their own names meanings and stories
attached to it japan too has its own
share of similar stories like the onibi
hitodama and kitsune all of which
describe a similar phenomena of flames
balls of fire or mysterious lights
floating around at night because there's
so many similar legends and eyewitness
accounts of this phenomena from
different cultures naturally people had
different interpretations of what they
could be ranging from evil fairies to
witches elves and of course the souls of
the dead their nature too is not
universal as some cultures view them as
harmless or even good while others saw
them as malicious evil or dangerous
because of this it's hard to put a
definitive stamp on what they are and
what their purpose is in a lot of
western folklore they are said to be the
spirits of the dead who attempt to lure
people deeper into the marshes after
which they sink into the swamp and die
or become irreversibly lost never to be
seen again the lights are seen as
deceitful tricksters and those who come
across one should avoid giving into
temptation and attempt to follow it the
japanese oneibi and hitodama are the
closest thing to the will of the wisp
and even translated as such on some
occasions according to the folklore
onibi are spirits born from the corpses
of humans and animals they are also
described as being resentful and having
been transformed into fire a famous
encyclopedia compiled in 1712 describes
them as a blue light like a pine
torchlight and that humans who come too
close would have their spirits sucked
out of them similarly the hitodama are
said to be the spirits of the deceased
who take on the shape of a flame as with
the wisps they are deceitful and play
tricks on the living such as getting
travelers lost they commonly appear in
watery areas like wetlands but also
forests prairies and graveyards the
similarities between the ornibi hitodama
and the willow the wisp seems to suggest
that whatever people saw back in the day
they are describing the same type of
phenomena as for their explanation well
there have been many from glowing fungi
to fireflies glow worms and more the
lights observed inside marshes and
swamps have often been attributed to gas
rising up from the bogs mostly composed
of methane this gas is known to
sometimes spontaneously combust and
methane also just so happens to burn a
pale blue color in the case of the
graveyard lights the element phosphorus
which is abundant in human remains such
as teeth and bones is used as an
explanation it too can apparently ignite
during specific weather conditions
creating flames that linger for a while
funnily enough ever since modern science
has started finding rational
explanations for the phenomena sightings
of the will of the wisp have become
almost non-existent it's not exactly
clear why though some suggest that this
is because since the 1600s a lot of
marshland has disappeared due to human
intervention and graveyards that feature
open bone pits are no longer a common
practice either because of the dancing
or swaying motions of the lights when
observed from a distance people often
associated them with lanterns or torches
a flame moving around on its own as if
being carried around by an invisible
ghostly entity it is also from where the
most famous halloween decoration the
jack-o'-lantern got its inspiration for
these lights were seen all over the
world and documented in books used in
stories and fairy tales and of course
inevitably made their way into fiction
as well especially in fantasy and horror
one famous example are the dead marshes
featured in the lord of the rings an
ancient battlefield turned into a
haunted marshland where the corpses of
the dead are still submerged in its many
bogs and lakes similar to the stories of
the wisp the dead inside the marsh will
attempt to draw people in joining them
in death which is why gollum wisely says
lastly we have the japanese paper
lantern ghost though in this case it's
the lantern itself that has become a
sentient being rather than it being
carried by a ghostly figure or
representing its soul it's based on the
belief that inanimate objects can become
alive when they reach an old age and
although it does involve a lantern it's
likely not the inspiration for the
ghostly flames in the zelda series as
the idea doesn't apply to lanterns alone
though it could have inspired other
zelda enemies or themes which brings us
back to the games it's clear to me that
the pose their lanterns in the fiery
soul they leave behind are based on the
stories and legends of the will of the
wisp and similar myths the same goes for
a lot of the other ghostly phenomena
seen in the games whenever someone dies
or crosses over to the underworld their
soul can sometimes linger often taking
the form of a flame most commonly a pale
blue or greenish flame in this state
they cannot interact much with the world
of light a possible reason why the posts
carry their souls inside of a lantern is
to protect or guard it from their
enemies alternatively it could be a way
for them to manifest into a physical
body capable of interacting with the
world of the living by housing their
soul inside of a physical object they
gain a foothold in the physical plane a
great example of this aside from the
pose is the spirit of king rome boss
varamus hyrule he too is seen carrying a
lantern around whenever he takes on the
form of the old man but as soon as he
reveals his true identity the lantern
disappears and he takes on the form of
an apparition surrounded by flames as
such it's likely that his soul is stored
inside the lantern as a way to hide the
fact that he's a spirit as well as a way
to gain a physical presence ghosts and
spirits will likely always have their
place in the series whether it's an
apparition a shadow a spirit animal a
lingering flame or a vengeful monster it
all depends on what role they once
played and the emotional attachment they
have to the world they inhabit poles are
resentful filled with hatred and rage
and thus they turned into a monstrous
entity who seeks to do harm the flames
they carry are what binds them to the
world of the living their true essence
as soon as this essence is destroyed
they will either cease to exist in this
world or end up in a glass jar for sale
at your local pharmacy
and that concludes the video happy
halloween and to those celebrating this
year stay safe and have fun a big thanks
to conrad for joining me in this one you
can check out his halloween video by
clicking the end card or the link in the
description below as always many thanks
to my mods on discord and live streams
and to my generous patreons and channel
members you guys are and always will be
the best and that is all for now this is
dawn signing off and have a good one
[Music]
so
[Music]
you